hey everybody i just got off the phone
with cam i told her
to stop antagonizing me with this tick
tock thing i'm a dad i have an opinion
i'm an american i'm a christian i'm an
entrepreneur and i'm not controlled kaye
west is speaking out against ex kim
kardashian and airing his struggles with
co-parenting amid the x's ongoing
divorce most men do not there's no such
thing as 50 50 custody
with with in society today that's not
that's not even
it always leans towards the mom
that's the rapper in a series of video
messages he shared to instagram on
sunday at this point it's it's going too
far god
please
among his rants yay takes aim at kim and
northwest's tick tock account i said i
am not allowing my daughter
to be used by tick tock to be used by
disney
uh
i have a say-so
in particular this video from last week
which has since been deleted
[Music]
yay complains he should have been
consulted before posting i just look at
my daughter full makeup singing she's in
love with the emo girl on tick-tock and
i have no say no approval hey what do
you think do you think this would be
cool or not yay gets particularly
emotional while discussing his sunday
service event he then criticizes kim for
allegedly not allowing northwest to
attend
north had a sleepover so she can't come
to sunday service
i moved the sunday service up to 10 a.m
so that i can go to st soccer game at 12
30. move the entire thing this morning
god please
you know there's no reason why these
young children
upon their father's request
shouldn't
be allowed to come to
sunday service
then there's a pete davidson of it all
the boyfriend texts me antagonizing me
gay dives into his recent alleged text
message exchange with a comedian he
texted me talking and bragging about how
he's in bed with my wife and i'm like
well who's watching
my children if he's texting me bragging
about being in bed with my wife and pete
is seemingly confirming the details
along with some added context following
kanye's rants snl writer dave cyrus
shared these now deleted screenshots to
instagram captioning the post quote a
message from pete pete allegedly says
quote i've decided i'm not going to let
you treat us this way anymore and i'm
done being quiet grow the [ __ ] up
kanye asks in his reply quote where are
you right now
davidson allegedly responds to this
selfie and writes quote in bed with your
wife
the tone of that text does shift to a
lighter tone and attempts to connect
with yay on a deeper level in the text
that appeared to come from pete the
message says quote i have your back even
though you treat me like [ __ ] because i
want everything to be smooth
but if you continue to press me like you
have for the past six months i'm gonna
stop being so nice
you understand the setup right here you
understand the narrative right here
by the afternoon both kaye's video
messages and the text message
screenshots were deleted from instagram
[Music]
you